just say no I haven't seen the original
I guess this movie is a remake of a
movie that's actually a true story point
is if you're coming here to see another
review of someone saying how the
originals some sort of wonderful
masterpiece I should never be touched
never be remain out here I'm the kind of
guy who wears Star Wars shirt while
reviewing the upside don't look for
logic
[Music]
the upside so the upside stars Bryan
Cranston and Kevin Hart Ryan Cranston
plays a quadriplegic named Phillip and
Kevin Hart plays a guy named L someone
who is completely unqualified to be
Philips caretaker so Phillip hires him
as a caretaker why not so now we have a
drama comedy drama date based on the
true story you know that means for sure
it's possible 20% of this [ __ ] might
have actually happened let's say
everyone in the movie did a fine job
like Nicole Kidman was good Bryan
Cranston did a good job Kevin Hart did a
good job I want to give props to Kevin
Hart because usually Kevin Hart's like
the clown of the movie and he is the
funniest one in this movie but he does
have to tone back the comedies like this
is not his most animated performance at
all this is a performance where Kevin
Hart's comedy needs to be used in a
movie that does have to have drama too
and it's the scenes with Bryan Cranston
and Kevin Hart that's where the movie
absolutely positively shines the two of
them are good together I thought they
had a good dynamic Bryan Cranston's
character doesn't really open up to
people he's kind of locked in his ways
and in comes Kevin Hart he just does
things differently
Philip learns to have fun Dell learns to
be responsible they're good for each
other that's what this movie is this
movie's a good kind of move it this is
the kind of movie you want to be like
you know what grandma you said you
wanted to watch a movie let's go watch
the outside the movies completely
watchable but also if you miss it it's
fine too it's cute movie does have
moments where you're like that was
clever or you're laughing movie does
have a moment I thought was the most
effective moment in the movie bummer is
in the trailer that room wrecking scene
was great but if you saw the trailer you
saw that's just a bummer you can't put
the coolest thing in the movie in the
trailer that's just kind of messed up
truth be told you seen a lot of people
bagging on this movie for the life of me
I don't really know why like I said
haven't seen the original maybe it's
because it completely pales in
comparison to the original but as
someone who hasn't seen the original
thought it was fine fine is the best I
can say the movies just fine I will say
so this movie had some weird editing
choices as strange as this may sound
there was a scene in particular I was
like that could have been a good montage
or part of a montage as it stands it's
just a scene in and of itself and it's
too short to even have in the movie so
why have it there are a couple scenes
like that in the movie I feel like those
are the makings of it that's what makes
people go you know we're gonna turn that
into a montage some of the transitions
in between scenes were a bit sloppy
passage of time you don't really feel it
and where the movie ends it just kind of
ends you're like wait is it gonna end
there it's not really don't fade to
black you're fading to black okay it
ends there alright it's just weird
editing choices throughout this movie
but in the end I thought the upside was
cute it's a movie you can watch with
your grandma maybe your mom if you and
the girlfriend or the boyfriend are
looking for a date movie and you just
don't want to wait for glass which I'm
sure would be a better date movie
I guess watch the upside I know everyone
else has the reviews for glass out but
in Seattle what can I say people don't
pay us respect up here i watch glass
next week so we just gotta wait for it
in the meantime the upside because
that's what people are really clamoring
for I'll just say this movie was a good
time no alcohol acquired right so the
upside have you seen it what did you
think about it are you waiting for a
review for glass you waiting to see
glass I'm excited to see glass I haven't
seen anything that anyone said about
glass I'm not going to I just want to go
into glass to whatever people are saying
whether it's good or bad don't tell me
don't put it in the comment section it's
almost daring you to put it in the
comment section but I don't wanna don't
tell me whatever you think about the
upside not glass comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you
[Music]